[Music]
[Applause]
columnist for the la times star of
around the horn bill plaschke joining us
on the program
bill thanks for joining us level of
concern over
repeating the lakers or the dodgers
right now
more people are freaking out about the
lakers really freaking out what's lebron
james doing in the game last night
it's so late in the blowout which it
didn't matter and he turned his ankle
again yeah people
people think the dodgers and i agree the
dodgers they've got a lot of season left
they got great pitching they're going to
make the playoffs they're going to be
fine
they may not be the best team in
baseball history as i predicted before
the season
not one of my finer moments but um but
they're going to be they're going to be
fine the lakers people are freaking out
because lebron's
you know they don't know how lebron's
ankle is ads fragile
they if if they win this thing it'll be
lebron's greatest achievement ever
because no team's ever come from a
seventh seed to win it no team's ever
had to win 17 games to win it
and the guy doing lebron's back and he's
been hurt most of the year and he keeps
getting hurt and
ads always you notice when a.d hits the
floor he's always wincing he's always
grimacing he's always groaning so he's
got all that going for him so yeah
there's
there's quite a bit of concern about the
lakers i think people think they'll
they'll get they'll beat golden state or
at least they'll get they'll get in this
seven or eight seed and they'll probably
win the first round
but i don't think people think they can
beat the clippers and i think that's
what
people are really concerned about out
here do you think the clippers tried to
avoid the lakers strategically
absolutely so did the nuggets
they were both fighting each other
trying to advance to all their players
absolutely they're trying to avoid the
lakers they're trying to wait till
they're trying to wait to get them
to the last round of the of the
conference finals but
that may not work by then the lakers
could be in rhythm and lebron could have
his confidence and they could be ruined
by that
i think you want to get lakers early
yeah
i agree with that but i was wondering
about with lebron and load management
like do you think that there's any
chance that maybe he
you know stayed out even longer just as
precautionary measures so he'd be ready
absolutely oh
i wrote before the season he should take
at least a one or two month vacation he
was mad
from the very start remember this dan he
was upset at the 71 game uh
you know break that's all they had he
wanted to start the season after january
so he was upset about that already yes i
think absolutely
he held out and that's why i think the
sky is not falling i think lebron and
a.d
i think they're both going to be fine i
think lakers going to win our
championship
but i think i think one of the reasons
is they're going to wake they're going
to wake up a month from now everybody's
going to realize how rested lebron is
and how rest their ideas and i think
clearly i think he nursed that ankle and
i think he
clearly wanted the vacation and smart
for him the nba
messed up schedule this year and the nba
was so messed up you all talked about it
on the show ad nauseam
all the injuries all the forced games
the rush games the compressed schedule
it made for a terrible terrible regular
season and lebron was just getting you
know just
paying him back he was just getting his
they do well against steph curry but
there's always that
if steph somehow goes crazy here
steph can't score 100 points i mean
can he well but let's say he gets 40
something
like when does it become dangerous here
oh he's got to get i just don't think it
ever becomes dangerous i just don't
think that's
i just don't think the warriors say
they're great to get this far they're
they're
a worthy opponent but no steph's the
whole team and i don't think
i don't think and i don't think i don't
think the lakers think that either
i think they their sights are set on
phoenix right now i think probably
i think they think they could beat
golden state i think that i think i and
and i would agree with him on that i
don't think this is but it'll be the
most watched game
remember the the last time they played
it was like 30 million people watched it
there'll be a me it's just going to be a
most watched
playoff game this early ever in history
but i just don't think it'll be much of
a contest
but do you think he truly believes steph
curry is the mvp because
his buddy chris paul has been equally
valuable for the phoenix suns but
lebron campaigning late for steph curry
no lebron thinks he's going to he should
be the mvp
he always does things he's no yeah he's
just he's just saying that
he was just saying that to uh jack up
this the game and get you know and maybe
get the steps head a little bit that's
that's what he was he was saying yeah no
i don't think he believes
i think he would vote for chris paul for
he'd probably vote for joel embiid
before he voted for he'd vote for jokic
he'd vote for yokish probably uh he's
vote for himself
he doesn't think yeah lebron don't think
anybody should be mvp ever but him
any year ever period is bill
plaschke of the la times contributor to
around the horn
what was your way dan when i started
destroy i was a star now i'm just a
contributor
i'll be lucky to be a freelancer about
time the show ends you said star
i said contributor so i i covered both
both currently woody page just texts me
and said he's a contributor you're not a
star
so he he's right he's actually correct
about that the accurate
uh your take away from the hall of fame
weekend was what
it sucked because kobe wasn't there i
don't care what
we wrote a million stories before this
the ceremonies we talked about colby and
wrote the whole history of his life
it was about colby and he wasn't there i
mean it just it really stunk to me
it was really obviously tim duncan's
speech was incredible i thought that was
really
really really incredible him talking
about pop was really incredible
rudy t's speech was off the hook off the
off the butt
i missed kobe and kobe should have been
there
to exchange jabs with the guys he should
have been there to thank
you know vanessa didn't thank any laker
and he didn't
did not mention any laker in her speech
because she didn't know what corby would
have said
she wasn't going to speak for her late
husband so a lot of lakers went
unrecognized i think a lot of the motion
was
drained out of the thing i just thought
it i'm sorry i know i'm supposed to be
emotional about i think it's so cool
that kobe's in and i'm glad he's in but
it really sucked that he wasn't there it
really stunk it was really i thought
the whole thing was just a real hard it
was real painful
it was supposed to be celebrating this
greatness and i thought we'd just
remember the absence of his greatness
and it was it was really hard i thought
it was hard
rudy tom jonovich though grabbed some
headlines when he said robert dory
belongs in the hall of fame
oh he does oh he does but he absolutely
does i was here for a lot of that
big shot bob he was the best player i've
ever seen under pressure
in the finals in in how many rings does
he have
i mean no i think if you're going to put
different people like that in the hall
i think absolutely he belongs to the
hall of fame for what we're going to
celebrate championships
if we're going to celebrate pressure
shots and pressure players and i loved
it because he would he said
he told me once the reason he was so
good
in april and may instead of early in the
season is that the kings
the l.a kings who shared the staples
center with them were done playing so
they got the ice out from under the
floor so the floor was warm
so it's his feet weren't cold in april
and may as long as the kings kept losing
and that's true story i thought i think
he should be
and he's a great guy too so put great
guys in the hall of fame really teasing
the hall of fame but put glory in hall
of fame
okay but is derrick fisher hall of famer
well he made a couple he didn't know i
don't think he had the impact that ori
had but he got
five titles he's got i know more career
points
he's played in more playoff games than
anybody in nba history
yeah but who's made more bigger shots in
ori for different teams
also fischer did it for the same team
how many different teams that oriented
championships with
but if i really i can put orie in but if
i put orien then all of a sudden am i
putting julian edelman into the pro
football hall of fame
well maybe so i just think we talk about
championships so much
and then we don't do anything to
celebrate them and these guys certain
guys are like that
and uh but i know i'm i know i'm in the
minority i'm sure most most people think
rob shouldn't be in there but i think i
was there and i saw it i saw his big
shots
all right he had the shot like the beat
sacramento
in game four the of the uh conference
finals
you know he had that great three-pointer
after that game glenn fry the eagles
walked past me in the press row
pounded his fist on the press table
looked at me and said the eagles never
wrote a song this good
and kept walking that that was
big shot bob that was robert dory
uh explain the logic of the dodgers
signing albert pujols
they're really desperate they're really
really desperate
for hitting against left-handed pitching
they really need someone
i think they're they have 13 players on
the injured list
they gotta they figure if they figure he
can win that if he can win them one or
two games with a late indian home run
maybe start a few games when they need
him at first base
just fill in they think and they think
the clubhouse
is veteran enough to absorb him and if
he complains or if he gets
disgruntled this is again i've heard
this this
analogy made many times but it's so true
david freeze worked in there
chase utley worked another they have a
history of getting veterans
who come in there and are tutors and
mentors
and then go into the system they're
they're banking on him
suddenly saying i gotta i can win a ring
i'll be quiet i don't need to play
and i think it's it's no lose for them
they don't do any good they just cut
them they don't care
they don't cost them harley anything
yeah my concern is he was not happy with
not getting playing time with the angels
now he's going to be happy with not
getting playing time with the dodgers
well i'm going to he's on a press call
today i'm going to ask him that
direct question or somebody asking that
question we'll find out that's that's a
concern dan that's a concern but i think
again you've seen players like this
veterans who have a chance to win a ring
the dodgers still have the best run
difference from the national league
they're still the best team in the
league
i think they learn to subjugate their
egos
and learn to and realize it's about
biggest it's about more than them
where the angels had no shock they have
no shot dodgers have a real shot
maybe he'll be more of a team player
there we'll see but that's a definite
that's gotta be one of the first
questions he's asked today in the press
conference i'll leave you with this if
you could start your team with one
kobe tim duncan kevin garnett
oh i'm taking kobe i'm taking kobe
because because i want to in
i want to start my team my team with a
guy who could end the game
who will end the game who will end the
moment who will own the moment
and tim duncan was great and garnett was
great but colby was a man on that
i would i would start how about you
uh if it was today's nba then i'm going
to take kobe
but if it's back in the you know 80s 90s
then i probably strongly consider duncan
i i think duncan's underrated
uh you know he won five titles he was
mvp in the finals three times he won two
league mvps
he was first or second you know all-nba
defense
15 years all-star 15 like he
he did everything you would ask a great
player to do
without any fanfare and really no
signature moment
he just he was kind of perfect for san
antonio i i wonder though bill if he
played
in la or new york or boston
would we be looking at tim duncan
differently if he had this resume
that's a great question because i mean
the guy like clayton
clayton kershaw is very quiet like
dunwood
and just does his job and he's revered
out here
but i want the copy brings the mamba
mentality i know that's such a cliche
and everybody laughs when they when i
say it yeah but i want my club to have
the mamba mentality that's why i want
kobe yeah
yeah i don't think there's a wrong
answer in there but
well i think kevin garnett would be a
wrong answer well he had a run there
where
he put up you know like 25 15
you know five block shots or four block
shots like he
he he put up some pretty big numbers
yeah he did but he wasn't didn't have
the
the consistency and the length of career
that these other guys did he didn't have
and he wasn't he wasn't as good as them
he just wasn't as good great to talk to
you he's the star
of around the horn your words not mine
your words not mine
and does a decent job as the columnist
for the la times housing
bill thanks thanks for joining us great
to catch up with you thanks see ya
bill plaschke we'll take a break play of
the day uh we have our best and worst of
the weekend coming up